Hello, hello, everybody.
Hello, oh, man.
You guys missed the greatest bit I've done.
Oh, you missed.
I was leaking so many things to you guys.
I was like, I'm going to tell you guys one time about this.
I'm not going to repeat myself.
Well, I guess, guys.
Guess you'll never know what I said.
Yep.
Guess what number I'm at in the queue.
Oh, yeah.
So, War Dogs having some issues right now uh they are
currently i don't know i just saw people seeing it in um on
streams and um in chat but apparently uh war dog is
currently going through a well it was going through a ddos
attack and now i think i don't know i think they fixed it
with the server updates or whatever apparently a lot of
updates and everything by the way um the game launched
around nine in the at first I thought about giving like
three hour buffer time and I was hanging out with uh sure
for and the crew uh because uh we're uh I'm planning we're
planning on sorry freaking I brain still waking up because
we're playing deadlock last night and uh uh we're planning
on you know joining up on their team uh for war dogs and
they're like oh yeah we're gonna be starting a little later
so I was like okay I'll just start the stream a little later
too because I don't want to like like because they play for
a long time too so it's like uh i don't want to like play
for like i have to play for like four hours just to reach
the part where they get on but it doesn't even matter now
because nobody can get on uh yeah um so um well good thing i
pushed the street because originally my intention was that
so we could join in time with uh my friend group um so i
wouldn't get absolutely destroyed playing the game um going
against someone going against some uh players who are like
on like 10 different types of drugs uh getting everybody
down um so at least i'll have like you know my friend group
there to like uh sustain so uh anyway uh so there they were
plans to playing the game later.
So I was like, all right, I'll, yeah, 50 doses of Adderall.
Exactly.
Uh, and, but then, uh, like I said, I found out that there
were survey issues.
So I was like, oh, okay.
Well, um, that, that helps out with me wanting to push back
the stream.
And yeah, the queue only four players, four new players got
on.
Um, yeah, we're all, stuck in queue uh all stuck in yikes I
don't know if there's like a whitelist for streamers or
anything I didn't get apparently like uh one of my friends
DMed my manager uh well it was like my manager's friend and
so we're like mutual it's like why did your friend not DM
you like sorry one of my uh manager and I's mutual friend
DMed their manager asking if I got whitelisted because on a
streamer server so that'll be easier to get in and I was
like what streamer server like I'm just like, what do you
mean a streamer server?
I'm fucking, I'm gonna rough it out.
I'm with, I'm one of the people.
I'm the, one of the people.
I'm one of you guys.
I'm gonna rough it out in the queue of all of you.
I'm down to earth.
I'm for the people.
Yeah, yeah.
One of us.
No, it does not mean I'm not cool enough.
I'm just so I'm down the earth guys.
I'm one of you guys.
I'm full of the people Yeah Yeah, so I was like two
streamers here really I was just like what do you mean
Anyway, so I'm so humble Papa thank you with super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you as a POE veteran the people's he was definitely
the smart choice Thank you for this super chat thank you
thank you uh so yeah apparently like i said they've been
having server issues the whole morning of launch uh they've
been having it since i guess like since nine in the morning
there's been apparently people would get into the server and
then um the server will fucking explode and everyone get
kicked out from what ben told me um so yeah i don't know how
long it is i debated about pushing the stream even further
but i'm just like i don't like it let's just Let's just rip
it.
Let's just let's order food.
I'm hungry.
I don't know what's all right guys Today's stream is you
guys helping me order food.
I don't know what to oh wait that.
Oh, I do have Nah, as I say, I do have some leftovers, but I
don't really feel like eating Leftovers right now because
it's just it's just like crab dip and I want something more
than just crab dip Oh, I could get kimp.
I've had kimpop in so long honestly
I hope I do feel like Kimpap.
Because like, all right, for me, Kimpap, it's like I have to
feel like I want to eat Kimpap, you know?
Because it's very filling.
Kimpap is super filling because there's like so many
ingredients in Kimpap.
It's really good.
I love Kimpap, but like I have to be in a specific mood for
Kimpap.
Let me see.
I'm going to get spam Kimpap.
Spam Kimpap.
It's like sometimes I would order kimbos like oh I want
kimbop and the kimbop arrives and's like oh I'm so I eat
like two to like two to three pieces and I'm more like oh
I'm so oh there's so much so much kimbop oh I've been too
much kimbop what is that um you know sushi it's it's sort of
like sushi Korean.
I think that's like the best way to explain for people who
don't know kimpop it's like the best way to explain what
kimpop is.
Oh yeah okay speaking of that okay I went I went to
international school um I remember when I was like when I
was in international school um there would be like arguments
got arguments between like Japanese students and Korean
students about like which was better and I'll just be
watching in the sideline because I'm not getting involved
with that
like they would be bringing the kimpop like the Japanese
series will have me eating sushi and the Korean series will
be in kimpop and then like every couple of months there'd be
an argument about which one is better and then the
non-Korean and non-Japanese series do not get involved.
We just, we, we just watch up the sidelines.
We do not want to be involved in this.
We let it, we do not intervene.
We do,
um, uh, 14 Davis, Richette, thank you.
Thank you.
Both, both is good.
Yeah, I like both kimpop and sushi.
I do tend to order sushi more than kimpop because, like I
said, like, sushi, a kimpop might get, like, full really
quickly, too.
So it's like, oh, I want, oh, no, I shouldn't get that.
Oh, I can get Korean fight.
Oh, no, I can't.
I know I'm not going to finish I'm not going to finish my
kimpop, so I shouldn't add anything more.
So I'm going to get oh, I'm going to get milkis.
I love milkis or milky.
I don't know what it was.
to pronounce it.
Oh, God.
All right.
Kimpop time.
I love, I do love Kimpop though.
I wish I could like eat more of it.
It's just like after three to four pieces, after three to
four pieces, there's still like half of like, there's still
like six more pieces left.
And I always feel bad because I feel like I'm wasting food.
Because I was like, I don't want to waste food but I was
like I'm so full and I hate putting like uh kimpop or sushi
in the fridge if I can't finish it so like it's like I have
to finish it or else like I like or else I'm wasting the
food because when I put in the fridge the rice will start
hardening and it's not as good you know I don't like I don't
like eating like uh sushi or kimpop when it's in the fridge
after it's been in the fridge it's just I just don't like
the texture of the hardened rice
oh yeah also uh also like surprisingly by the way guys i
finally unlocked deadlock rank uh last night um but you know
what's surprising surprisingly i did not realize i don't
know i don't realize this but uh well i mean i mean i
realized the one was happening but i meant like more so like
um i get And it was very surprising for me because it's
like, out of all the games, I think in Deadlock, I get
recognized the most.
It was very surprising for me.
Because, you know, I would think like it would be like
Rivals, you know, or like Overwatch.
But actually in Deadlock, there's like a lot of people would
be like, is that the real Dokeybird?
Or like, is that Dokeybird?
Or, hey, Dokeybird.
And I'm like, I'm like, I'm not Dokeybird.
but the thing is i don't you know i didn't really i didn't
really play deadlock too like i only recently started
playing deadlock like last week or i don't even i think last
week i only recently started playing deadlock last week so
it's very surprising for me to see like so many people
recognize me in game and then it was really funny because
you know i would be playing with like um the sure fort group
and and it would be so funny because like everyone will be
like on like They'll be on their Steam accounts, but their
Steam account names will be different and Shreveur will be
an alt account And then so I'll be the only one with the
like Doki Bird And then the others would be like, you know,
different names So like you're not like recognizable And it
was so funny, we won a game And obviously like I wasn't
doing jack shit Like I was Ivy with 12k damage And then
Shreveur was like was like 100k damage or some shit And then
um Um, but it was so funny because uh um after like we won
the game someone the enemy team was like okay sure for his
name was his name was ba and like buh ba and then it would
be so funny because like the enemy it was so funny because
the enemy team was like uh ggs ggs bun dokey bird oh wait no
no not even no they didn't even name drop sure for it
because sure was playing victor and then they were like ggs
victor and dokey bird and then everyone like in in discord
everyone was like what the they name dropped I was like,
wow, that 12K damage, baby.
Like, I was like, yeah.
They're like, they didn't even name sure before.
They didn't even say bye.
It was just like, good job, Victor and Tokeybrain.
And I was like, oh, look at that.
Look at this 12K damage, everybody.
Whoa, yeah, all meme.
All, all, it's stolen value.
Yeah, yeah, I'm just like, yeah.
I'm like, well, I did the, I did that.
Yeah.
Um, I haven't done my placements yet, uh, for deadlock.
Because like I said, it's like, it's solo queue only.
And I have to be in the right mindset to be yelled at.
Like, I debated if I wanted to like stream my rank
placements too.
Because it's not going to be pretty.
It's, I have to be in the, you know, like I said, being the
right man said, to yell that for eight games because that's
eight hours and give or take eight hours like that's eight
games equals eight hours and i don't know if i'm ready for
that commitment um no the thing is vc is so important in
deadlock because it's a moba game so you have to know what
the fuck is like going on because like they'll just suddenly
be like let's do mid boss and then i'll be on the other side
of the lane be like why is everyone going mid and yeah so um
so yeah so like rank placements has to be solo queue you
can't even do or anything because they want to make sure
like it's all fair um and everything uh so so yeah we'll see
we'll see if i maybe i'll do some placements uh also i
forgot how to play rem because i was spamming ivy for the
last three days because i just wanted to get it over with so
i um so i legit i got rem for one game and i was like i
don't remember how to play him like i was like i was missing
i was missing all my pillows i was whiffing shit i forgot to
send my minions to people and i was just like oh this is bad
i gotta play some rem again i no i had to make that
sacrifice to unlock rem i had to i had to spam ivy to get it
over with so i can finally play rem for the rest of my life
guys It's a I don't know if it was dragoons or just people
who like heard of me Um, it was really cool to be recognized
I was just very surprising for me like I said because I
don't um, oh shit the stream There's a stream that no don't
sit don't don't do this to me No, we should be back right?
Yeah, we're back.
It was just I think it was YouTube being YouTube honestly
Uh, it's just YouTube being YouTube guys, uh, because it was
Uh Um, because I'm still in queue yeah I'm still in queue
wait what was I saying um patricia thank you the super chat
thank you thank you the first tips and new players and do it
to our often told us the first time someone say someone
wearing a voice chat you meet them their comms ain't worth
it thank you with super chat thank you thank you oh yeah
like I said it was very surprising that it was deadlocked
that a lot of people recognized me um like I said because I
don't play MOBAs.
And only a week ago, I started playing Deadlock.
So it was really cool.
And I always say no.
That's not me.
Just to fuck with them.
They'll be like, anyone could be fucking change your names
to be Doki Bird.
And they're like, oh my God, I thought I met Doki, but it
was, I guess it wasn't her.
But it was me.
sometimes I don't even say anything too sometimes I don't
even give and a reply because so it makes you even more
paranoid like why isn't she saying anything usually if it is
dokeybird she will say no but this one doesn't even say
anything so make you so then you're it makes you over and
think be like is that really her or is that someone
pretending to be her but then you see told you guys what
sure first alt account name is then if you see ba it's me
well unless you see ba then it's me then it is me then you
see a guy named ba and he does a hundred million damage and
he and he one v8s your team then that's me then then it
might possibly be me uh yeah all right let's see when is my
food here um his calico gun bill has been fun but it is it's
pretty funny um every time i see uh every time people on the
enemy team would be like fuck ba and they'd be like ba
when he shoots his gun and my computer overheats uh oh yeah
he was doing gun page last night but then people they're
like they're like this page has the secret chinese build i
was like what the fuck does that even mean and then people
they're like what the fuck is this page doing but he was
killing everybody as as gun page and oh it's a game loud i'm
so sorry was it really loud oh i didn't even realize i'll
turn it down yeah and the enemy team was like what the fuck
is your page doing bro he's cooking he's cooking some shit
this is destroying us uh wait was i tapped into the game the
entire time because i tapped out i had my volume lowered so
um i lowered it already oh i'm still 142k i've been having
fun i've been having fun in deadlock but i think it's
because i'm having fun with friends and we're winning lose
if we i was i'm winning and i'm getting hard carried i'm
having so much fun i think the moment i go to solo queue i'd
be fucking miserable
um let's see oh my gosh 142k i hope like will be i the only
thing i'm worried about is just being able to be on the same
team as my That's the only thing I'm worried about.
Oh, yeah.
And then also, when I was playing them last night, he was
like, Hey, Sudoki, why did you join our war dogs server?
And then after I mortared you, you left.
And I was like, what the fuck do you mean?
I had a stream.
I was like, why did you keep mortaring that area?
And he's like, I was like, fucking getting called.
I was like, But it was like, not you, SharePoint.
I had a stream, but it did help that I, thank God I had a
stream.
It did help that, though.
Did you guys see the, okay, fly update.
I'll give you guys a fly update.
They now train the fly to do inside, like, not, sorry, not
inside trade.
They now train the fly to do trading.
I don't know, was it like stocks or cryptocurrency?
Let me double check.
Oh yeah, Bitcoin.
I gave the fly brain $100 to trade Bitcoin.
Dopamine neurons are stimulated when the fly makes profit.
Neuron activity controls a buy, sell decisions, and makes
trades on Coinbase.
Will the fly get rich?
Yeah, so now the fly can trade Bitcoin.
And also, by the way, guys, the code is fully open source.
So you, too, can have your fly trade Bitcoin.
Also, apparently, he made a website where you can see if the
fly is making money or not.
Currently, not so much.
Did I keep it literally?
So this fly, this simulated fly, who doesn't know he's in
the simulation.
um is now this is trading uh is now trading for bitcoin uh
and forget ai would all be replaced by flies meanwhile i go
to mean girl doki she denies being doki well thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you the fly will eventually
learn what else what else is there well i know they oh yeah
and then they also they the fly brain can play doom um so
for those who are like but can they train a fly to play doom
yes someone created a a simulation of the fly actually in
doom he he can indeed do it and don't worry that the ever
don't worry they thought of everything as it should be the
first thing if you're making a simulation or like trying to
make a reconstruction reconstructing a brain the first thing
you should always try is to see if they can play doom oh did
you guys see um so one of my friends sent me a link to it
but like some ai dude um that was like uh big in the ai
scene um that was helping developing open ai and the one I
don't remember I'm not like a huge follower of AI um he like
officially quit the company because he was like humanity is
fucked if we are going and I'm like huh that's not a good
sign and I was like humanity is fucked with if we keep going
the pace we're going and letting AI do all of this and I'm
like huh well then Hmm.
Oh, God.
We're creating sky.
And I'm like, hmm.
That might not be it.
That doesn't sound reassuring.
I'm like, oh, oh, no.
We're Sarah Conner when we need it.
I know.
Oh, no.
Uh.
Yeah.
If it's real, it's not doomed in the way people.
I hope so.
Oh, that was 100% publicity stunt.
I don't believe anything.
Oh, I hope so.
I hope it was a publicity stunt.
Because I was like, huh.
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm like, hmm.
Petra suit.
Yeah, I'm like a Minecraft villager.
Hmm.
As the world's ending because of AI.
oh patria say thank you super chat thank you thank you
remember how school started teaching research skills when
google took up the opposite happened with ai people are
getting are genuinely getting worse at research skill than
they were a generation ago neat yeah because if you can just
do like you can just make a prompt and like there's no
there's no reasons to research because the ai can research
it for you but it's also like you're not really how uh
building your critical skills or your analytical skills
because what you're what you're supposed to do when you're
doing taking when you're reading research you're when you're
researching it yourself you have to like you know
compartmentalize it uh in a way that you understand it but
then if you have ai explain it to you and you just copy and
paste like do you really understand what you're researching
um and being able to you know like you know how they're like
oh make sure you summarize this and explain in your own
words what ai is is like already like giving you a shortcut
and you not doing that but then you're not using any
critical thinking skills or your analytical skills to like
make sure you're understanding what you're reading and what
you're trying to research uh you're just yeah you're just
being spoon-fed of the information but you're not actually
like taking it in and stuff and they also like help you grab
all the research and like you know put it all together
themselves rather than you you know i want everyone else to
suffer you know i also
And it's not fair that these kids don't have to go through
what I did.
Going to the library and going to Google Scholar and
annotating your sources.
And everyone else should suffer the way I suffer when I had
to write research papers.
But...
Yeah.
But I have heard, like, I have heard, like, teaching as well
has gotten really bad, only because, like, like, I said,
like, I think I'm getting more stupid, too, because I'm
watching a lot of brain rot.
I feel like I'm getting brain rotting hard from, like,
YouTube shorts, and also, like, watching videos of, shows
that I've never watched before but they try to they try to
like shorten it and within 60 seconds or less and so like
even I can feel that I'm I'm also getting dumber and I
honestly I've been like like a contemplating like I talked
about before but I've been like thinking about getting back
into reading as well just to like uh slow down the declining
rate of my IQ uh my brain cells dying one by one like just
slow it down like there's no like I can still salvage this
you know because you can't grow new brain cells by the way
um I can still salvage this in some way and by reading like
that's the only thing I can think of is like if I start
reading again maybe I'll slow down the the rate of the dot
death rate like the speed of death yeah uh yes but no I have
heard that like uh so one of the uh I have heard that it's
getting harder to be teachers because like we also don't
know uh teaching is also like less people are going into
teaching too so there's shortage of teachers because it's
like it's not a thing like it's a thankless job basically
because like your kids are so mean as we all know children
are really really mean they haven't developed their empathy
sensors yet uh yeah so like kids were already mean but now
new gen children are like a whole new level of sadistic
little fucks like Like, the, okay, also, like, because with
AI, like, we're going with AI, the fear that your students
are, uh, the fear that your students are taking pictures or
video recordings of you, and then make, feeding you, and
then making you an image prop or a video prop is scary.
Like, that's, that's fucked up.
Like, you're like, you know, you know, the kids are AI
generating something regarding you as a teacher.
Yeah.
Also, I just saw a tweet related to that where like
apparently a teacher was like, you're no longer to record or
take pictures of like, I guess like lecture sessions or like
online lectures or whatever, because apparently a student
was feet, oh my God, was feeding it into an AI.
To do stuff with it, and I'm not gonna explain more.
Yes, that one.
Outlet, whatever Outlet said, yes.
It had to back.
Oh my god, it wasn't even online.
Okay, that's even fucked up that it was an in-person class
session.
So yeah, so phones were banned from classes because the
teacher got a student taking like recordings and pictures AI
for stuff and I'm like that's fucked like I'm like oh my god
that's scary like oh and also like other than that like I
think kids in general are just more mean now because I feel
like I think it's just an online thing like it desensitized
a lot of people like I'm desensitized via like my um
exposure to the online world um and i definitely think like
um it also also because you have to check a student's
homework or like papers or essays um whether or not they use
chat gpt or ai to do their homework for them and i feel like
that's one of the hardest parts as a teacher because you
don't know because there's been so many cases of like uh
what's it called like like accusing someone we're using ai
and then losing their entire like getting kicked out of
school slash university because it was a false accusation
that they used ai but they didn't so there's like so much
risk involved to being like oh like is this person actually
using ai because like ai check sometimes ai checkers are
wrong um and like there's some like like instances where the
tools to detect it uh got some got it wrong so there's like
and then they had to like and then they had to feed it to
another ai checker and then then they'll be like oh no
that's not ai um yeah they're they're very unreliable uh so
so it's it's you know i'm glad i you know i'm glad i didn't
uh go to school when ai started becoming really and also
like I'm glad I finished school before before COVID happened
because I don't know if I could I don't know if I could
handle doing online session online school like online
lectures and like online exams and stuff because like for
those who don't know when you do online exams they are much
more strict on what because they're like oh you're online
like you should be able to do like a really well in these
essays like online essays in a timed environment and then
but then if i do my if i do exams in person then they'll be
more lenient and how they grade me because like oh she was
like um she was timed and it was all from her brain of what
she's writing and everything so like even if i like you know
uh even if i like don't like you know if i like my essays
like sort of mediocre it would it would have been like okay
like they'll be like you know what she did her best right
like you know she tried so i'll give her like a b plus for
try but if i submit that same essay on online it'll be like
an f like she was in a timed environment she only had like
two hours like like one and a half i don't remember one and
a half hour two hours you know she tried you know like yeah
um solid thank you the super chat thank you thank you don't
forget the parents and the education side and recovery come
from the jobs a valid uh validate of that validly failed
students source x teacher friend thank you for the uh super
chat thank you oh yeah i heard Like, parents are like, uh,
my, my son's not stupid.
You're stupid.
Like, my son is special.
He's just not being, uh, he's just not motivated in your
class because your class sucks because you're a bad teacher.
My son, my son would definitely pass the class if you were a
better teacher.
So it's not his fault.
Yeah, I've heard a bunch of shit.
like that too.
My SAC.
Thank you.
The super chat.
Professors are using AI too.
I had a question about a lecture and the professor gave me
an AI response instead of answering through email.
Thank you.
The super chat.
I heard like professors even use AI to like to like mark
papers now too, which is also a bit yikes.
Oh, all right.
Where are we at right now?
Where are we at?
Bup, bup, bup.
Wait, Queen Elizabeth died on September 8th?
What is up with the first week of September?
Oh, sorry.
The second week of September.
I just...
I realized Queen Elizabeth died on September 8th as well.
What is the...
this timeline.
Haru Aurora, wait, Haru Aurora died on September 9th.
Do you remember?
Wait for the years drop.
Yeah, so 8th, 9th, 10th, and 11th.
Wow.
Curse the week.
Not even cursed month.
Damn, that was that that's crazy that's actually crazy i did
not i'm i'm scrolling on twitter guys it's it's what are we
at where are we even at anymore all right we're down guys
we're down a hundred k at least
at least at least it's a hundred k less all right what else
what else new update life update uh let me see let me see oh
yeah do you guys see the oh man the resident okay I would
never do this because uh I'm a little bitch I'm a little
pussy when it comes to haunted uh haunted mansions is that
what it's called like haunted houses yeah haunted houses um
but I can never do a hunt i watch videos of it i would never
like actually do it in person i like watching videos of it
because it's just like you know i'm living vicariously
through the person um but uh i always find it super
interesting like like i like the set design and like the
world building that they do for haunted houses oh i got
goosebumps listening to that video uh but for those who
didn't know universe like i talked about it yesterday but
universal studios is uh doing a very collab with Resident
Evil for Halloween and they just showed a preview of the
Resident Evil haunted house and that shit looks actually
really good like the set design they actually included the
fucking the horse the goddamn horse the horse statue oh yeah
and also Universal Studios They did, you know, there's like,
you know, walking, you know, walking creatures or, I don't
even know, walking, like, performers, I guess that's what's
the word, walking performers roaming around Universal
Studios, they added the Otaku Zombies.
And I, they added, you know, they have zombies walking
around Universal Studios in Japan, and then they, this year,
they added Otaku Zombies to the Universal Japan.
had an experience and I thought that was so funny I thought
it was so clever let me see I can find it I saw photos of it
let me see uh where's the otaku zombies I saw I didn't
bookmark I wish I bookmarked it because I thought it was so
funny I was like what the fuck let me say I could find it
guys Let's see.
Otaku.
Universal Studio.
Oh my god.
I wish I...
I wish I bookmarked it.
Because it was so funny.
Like the costume design was so funny.
Zombie.
Alright.
i'm scrolling guys i will find it really it's just the risen
evil stuff right now
maybe no i just bookmark everything just in case if ever if
if ever elon musk is like decides to self-destruct all of
twitter by making likes public again i bookmark everything
Just in case he's feeling a little quirky and decided to
press the self-destruct button and be like Likes are public
now and the world is ending
Let's see
Oh my god, I saw I think it was like a Japanese tweet so
it's like harder to search too Zami, Otaku, I'm going to
Google it, Otaku.
Me Googling it.
Because it was a Japanese tweet, so it's even harder to
find.
No!
Why didn't I bookmark?
Why did I bookmark it?
It was so funny when I saw, like, the...
When I saw the pictures of it, too.
Booksmarks are now public.
Like, yeah.
Oh my god, there's a zombie bar Wait, they're so immersive
Look at this There's like a zombie There's a zombie bar
They're like plus one RP right here Plus one RP The only
issue I will say about Universal Japan Is that the lines are
fucking crazy Like I have a few like oh my god like the
lines are like too much that's my biggest gripe about
universal japan but yet you have to find a day where there's
no lines well there's always going to be a line but like the
least amount of lining up possible
yeah it's just you it's like like you know maximum one hour
like i i maybe I can tank an hour oh there you go I found
the otaku zombies I'm not going there on a rainy day guys
yeah your otaku zombies I found it guys it came back it came
back into the algorithm came back into my feed the otaku
zombies yeah I don't man a sunny day with no one else here
yes i was really cute that they hold pen lights too i'll
show it oh my god i'm not i'm under 100k guys we're doing
i'm under 100k guys we made it bare minimum i'll show it
here i love the costume designs for Universal Japan.
I've always wanted to go Universal Japan for Halloween.
Just because I feel like Japan loves Halloween.
And it's like, they go all out in it.
I mean, like, in Japan, it's less about horror, too.
It's like, I mean, it is horror, but it's more creative with
their horror and stuff.
Because, like, okay, in America, it's just all gore.
It's just gore and uh gore and like violence and like jump
scares and stuff when it comes to like american like haunted
houses or like theme park themes unless you're in disneyland
like it's funny like in disneyland in america like the
horror stuff there is like very tame like you know child
friendly horror and then uh and then but then you do like if
you go to disneyland in asia like they go all out.
They like, I remember I showed you guys like in Hong Kong
Disneyland, like they actually went full on.
What if like, what if Pinocchio, what was important?
What if the Mad Hatter was a murderer, like a serial killer?
And this was Hong Kong Disneyland, by the way.
They're like, what if the Mad Hatter was a fucking serial
killer and he killed everybody at the tea party?
I'm like, Jesus Christ, wait, this is this is Disneyland.
Yeah.
I showed a video of it.
That was crazy.
I was like, holy shit.
What the fuck?
It's like, yeah, you see that that's Pinocchio.
Yeah, it's not great being a real boy, is it?
Yeah.
So, um, yeah, it was fucking crazy.
Like, I showed you guys a video for a long time ago.
But if you look up this Hong Kong Disneyland Halloween, they
had like some crazy like haunted houses and stuff where
where you're like holy shit
um um and but like I always think like in Asia uh I think
like Halloween and stuff is like done a lot more creative
like more more creatively and more interesting in my opinion
so I love seeing like videos of like that's why videos of
like stuff they do for Halloween in theme parks and that's
why I really I've always wanted to go to Universal Japan
during Halloween because I feel be it'd be i don't know i
just feel like it'd be so cool like just experience it and
uh like the different vibes of it compared to like american
theme parks when they celebrate halloween um uh because like
i know it's like it's scary but like not like as like scary
like it's not as scary scary as like american theme park
halloween like halloween too um only because like i don't
know like like in like hot like universal japan like not
universal japan universal america nights it's a lot it's
really crazy looking at the videos in general yeah
i mean we're at 73k oh my god 73k
what are the haunted houses for universal america right now
universal haunted houses all right I saw like I saw a video
of it about like they had like special There's a special
theme one Um, all right, what is universal?
There's the fortnight opening ceremony.
What the fuck?
What's fortnight?
What oh, but
I was like, what do they mean by fortnight?
Is it actually like it is what it is It is, it is exactly
what it, the name implies.
So, apparently Fortnite did a special collab with Universal
Studios, Hollywood.
It got a Fortnite night.
Yeah, so Fortnite, that was because I was like, is this a
play on words or something?
But no, no, it's real, it's Fortnite.
It's just Fortnite.
characters doing an opening ceremony we go to 10 seconds in
that's just that's just fortnight they're emoting they're
actually emoting with the purge lady what is the purge lady
doing there with fortnight what is all right let's see So
this year's This year's Haunted house stuff Is they have The
sinner's haunted house Dead deader Okay they would have like
creative like original haunted houses too I don't know but I
don't know what dead deader And dead is I assume that was
like Oh gee evil dead Hellraiser The hellraiser Ozzy Osborne
Clowns from other space stranger things and Kielsenera Nero
I heard the Kielsenera one is really scary I heard that one
was apparently really really scary because I saw like a clip
of that earlier I always love every year I always love
looking at the haunted houses of what they come up with and
stuff like because I like the prop design and the set design
of it too okay there was one apparently that was like Let's
see, haunted house.
Oh, my gosh, guys.
When will I be let in?
When will they let me in?
Okay.
Let's see.
Bum, bum, bum.
Oh.
Apparently there's an all-year Halloween horror night?
Oh shit, Halloween horror, Halloween Horror Nights in Las
Vegas.
Whoa, wait, they made the Halloween Horror Nights in Las
Vegas only.
Oh shit, what's my number?
Wait, oh my god, oh my god, this is a moment in my career.
Wait, I got a screenshot.
I got it, it's happening.
the caption B stop the queue I've already got my word nice
you are the player it's beautiful nice I'll just do nice
right there I'll just do my caption nice there you go I
can't believe it I I'm the chosen one I am the chosen one
stop everything close the servers peak has been made I don't
need anything more all right I'm good now it's time to shut
off the servers I love weight dogs.
Coffee.
Thank you.
Super chat.
I beat the game.
I got everything I needed.
There's no point.
There's no point, guys.
There's no point in keeping to keep going.
Oh my gosh.
I want to check if they're... I'm going to check if they got
in yet.
Have you guys got in yet I I'll show them look at me the 20
start 26k oh my god they had 26k I think that's it everyone
I think I've seen it all shut it down.
Yeah, don't be playing for an hour before I get in.
Holy shit, I don't even know what to do while we wait,
honestly.
Let's see, what do I have that we can just pull up?
Alright, I'll just have to join.
Wait, how is my food here?
Bloons time game if we can get here in 10 minutes let me
look at my steam library guys we'll see what we can do while
we wait and pull up battlefield i mean it's all almost like
war dogs when in doubt
let's see i'm trying to see what i have in my other things
oh there was a supporter pack oh fuck i'm not downloading
that 16 yeah fuck that uh let's see hot wheels oh it's a hot
wheels driving game
is there is there what game what game oh did you guys see oh
my gosh i'm so sad i wasn't there for the sex update for
halloween the game so you guys know you guys know halloween
the game uh that is basically like friday the 13th but they
lost you know how they lost their licensing for friday the
13th so then they made a new game for halloween the game and
then um so for those who didn't know in halloween let me uh
oh dad and dad was like i heard about it uh so in halloween
the game so it's like literally just friday the 13th um and
um it's like apparently really buggy too uh hey no no no no
go back no food we already had your food so yeah with
michael meyers yes so one of the mechanics is that you get
to bang
I don't think it's other players.
I think it's...
I assume it's not other players.
But it's like...
So in the game, it's sort of like Friday 13th, but also not
really.
So it's like maximum four players.
It's like Friday 13th slash Dead by Daylight.
In a way where like...
You have to save the civilians in your town.
In your city.
Okay, it is with other players.
Okay, it's other players.
Alright, never mind.
Okay, I love this tweet though.
I love...
So, alright, because I don't, because like, there's NPCs
there too, so it's like a little mini game, and it's called,
it's the sex, it's the sex mini game.
And I love the community note, where it's like, sex has been
included in the new Halloween game.
And in the community note was, sex is no longer included in
the new Halloween game.
It gives you bugs, by the way.
And you get You get bumps through that So the reason I think
one of the reasons Why they had to remove it Was because Was
because you can play as an older man And then other people
can play as Teenagers So they're like Oh that's a problem
man That's a problem Oh my
shit!
Oh my god!
It's so...
So they removed...
Oh, they removed it.
Someone did not think that through adding the sex update in
the Halloween.
Um...
Yeah.
Not a good look for them, that's for sure.
Um...
So...
Yeah, yeah.
So they removed it and then It was wild I thought about it
But I didn't know I didn't have time to like set up a collab
for it Cause I thought about like streaming the game On like
during like Beta like close I assume it's like pre-order
beta or whatever the fuck Cause you can pre-order it's
strong You get the buffs stronger together So I thought
about it It would be crazy if like we experienced that live
maybe like finding out that there's a sex mechanic it would
have been fucking wild if we found that out together like
but they did remove it i heard it's very janky though um um
i heard the game is super janky and stuff like you can die
from just riding on a bicycle and hitting a car and And then
Michael Myers, like, I win.
It's like, I didn't do that to do anything at all.
You literally just ride a bike around town and just fucking
slam into a car and you're just dead.
You just fucking die.
Intended feature, exactly.
Lolly, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I love to stay and watch, but I got asleep to not miss an
appointment.
Have fun, dokey.
Enjoy the stream, fellow dragoos.
Maybe I'll see you then.
Thank you, super chat.
Thank you.
We're almost there.
guys just like real life yes realism has gone too far oh my
god we've only moved up oh my god we've only moved up a
little bit i'm gonna go get why i'll be right back guys i'll
make sure i'll let you guys listen to sick ass bgm
i'm back uh and Four, Mike, Neppers, Medi, Jayla, Cone,
Solid, Do you have a super chat?
Do you think?
Yeah, I got some water inside me now.
Oh, my God.
All right, let's look through my Steam library and see what
we can do while we wait.
And also get a cough drops.
Oh, oh, what can we do?
Oh, what kind of games can we do?
Any fun games coming out today?
Any like throwaway games that I can play today?
Halloween clearly.
What's the point?
They removed the update.
They removed the whimsy.
Let's see.
Oh, wait, I got a game.
I have a game we can play while we wait.
Um, I have an idea.
Let me put...
That's not the one I want to do.
Oh, where is War Dogs?
War Dogs?
Okay.
Wait.
Here.
It'll be like here.
It's a game about skipping.
I'm really bad at this game.
I bought it to be like, I'm better.
I can be better than you in this game.
And I was absolutely not better at my at this game.
It's the only reason why I bought this game, too.
Because I was like, I think I can beat you.
And I couldn't.
So for those who don't know, this game was made by one
person.
Oh, shit.
I'm like lagging.
Wait, am I?
But for those who don't know, this game was...
Oh, fuck.
Maybe I should not have...
Like, give me a sub.
Let me see.
My PC might be like...
like over here right now you're like oh my god my cpu is at
94 but he's like please kill me you see it's not happy right
now it actually went to 90 boys and kill me and kill me so
for those who don't know what oh my maybe if i'm in the game
it'll be maybe okay wait i got an Oh my god.
Don't do low.
Maybe.
Okay, there we go.
It's a game about skipping.
Alright.
This was made by one guy who used to do porn stuff.
Well, not he didn't do porn.
He would draw, animate porn stuff from what I've heard.
And now he's a game developer.
I mean, you can sure tell.
Apparently.
I don't know who the guy is.
Okay, let me put on a text.
Made by one guy with one...
This is...
War dogs.
Look, Kate, I'm 63,000 in queue.
Okay, let me...
This is why I need to put the text in.
Text.
Oh, shit.
My food's here.
Now I'm actually gonna play this game with one hat because
I'm eating my food.
that waiting in queue right so we play jump rope there we go
all right
um how fucking know where we put this put it here all right
I think it was like increased luck all right
poop all right it gets harder guys do not
i i blame my dog guys he fucked up with the rhythm he fucked
with my rhythm with the barks i had a rhythm going and then
his barks Fucked with my rhythm.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
1.
2.
At least I can use mouse click.
It's because, like, it's so slow at first.
And I just get antsy.
I'm like, please jump faster.
Alright.
God, I need it to go faster.
Wait.
Okay, we gotta do luck.
Luck is the way to go.
We don't really care about the jumps.
Dad has opinions.
Griffin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, Day.
And we'll get double jump rope after that.
Oh, okay.
Well, increased luck again.
I feel like I know this art style.
Someone's outing themselves right now.
Where did you know this art style from?
Hmm.
Yeah, one day.
I don't even know who the artist is.
I just heard that this person who will reinforce just
because I know I'm going to fuck it up.
Alright, 37.
I don't remember what my high score was.
Not that high.
I only played it like one.
one time because I was like, I can play business.
I could beat your highest score.
And then I and I gave up after like like 20 minutes.
I was like never mind.
Wait, why is the cube blurred?
Wait, why, why is the cube blurred?
Why?
I'm Actually in the trenches, right?
Broken seas.
Like it was
a...
It's another game!
But...
What is it?
Am I being punished?
Am I being punished for playing jump rope?
For playing this game?
Oh!
This is my Punishment for cheating on war dogs.
I said cooners in the back of the line Not that even is this
my punishment?
Oh,
yeah, apparently I was supposed to just sit there and watch
the queue numbers go down.
Apparently.
I was supposed
to eat more doctor serves all of my attention.
Some of my food.
Here, let me.
Let me go grab my food.
Apparently, I was a dedicated adult.
I've been a bad little boy.
I go back in the line.
I go.
But back in the line, I go.
I was just jumping rope.
It wasn't even
a plank jump rope.
I...
I really got no terrorism to just keep waiting.
So thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
There you are, go.
I guess I'll jump rope again.
Nope.
Do not do this luck.
Oop.
Nice.
War dark demands loyalty.
Please, I don't want to wait three hours.
Ah, everything sucks.
I like it.
Alright, I just got...
and two all right we'll get let me just jump high we gotta
start jumping high all right here we go or at least get a
hundred i guess 89 90 91 92 93 94 95
96 97 nothing ever i'm what do you mean isn't this rigor
rate reverating isn't this exciting oh my god she's jumping
look at her go
it's past a hundred
no wonder all my friends are playing war dogs right now yeah
this is war dogs guys
all right here we go guys we're gonna do it we're gonna hit
200 well
what if maybe they'll add servers but they had like 500
servers while i'm while i'm in the middle of this guys and
they'll go from 300 to like 5.
Oh, shit.
That just scared me.
I go from 300 to 5 in like in 10 minutes, guys.
They're adding the new servers right now.
Nice.
I think the worst part is just it takes a... It's like a
slow burn, you know?
Guys, it's a slow burn.
When it hits, it hits.
When it hits, it hits, guys.
We're almost there.
Okay, well, I had another jump rope.
So, all right, there you go.
Look at that, look at it's starting.
It's starting to hit.
Guys, it's starting.
We're almost there.
Okay.
All right.
Just need more luck.
I'll make this go a little faster.
Two of them.
Oh, I got dopamine.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You feel it, dopamine, guys?
You feel it, dopamine?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, we're getting luckier now.
Is it?
Should level up faster.
Alright.
Here we go.
Uh.
I'm not risking another one.
I already... I don't know if it might.
Yeah.
I'm needing more luck.
Okay, nice.
That's what And then after that, we'll increase the jump
height.
Alright.
It's okay.
The dopamine's coming in.
Don't worry.
There's going to be more jingle jangles.
So I just need to increase my jump height.
There we go.
That's why I need it, actually.
Like that.
I think I can...
I think I can do another jump rope.
Alright.
We're getting there.
Oh, that was a little risky.
Got a little too confident in there.
Uh...
You know what I think you do jump rope speed.
Yeah.
I got the beat going.
Look at that.
Oh.
Okay.
I had to look at the...
I wanted to double check if the sound was okay.
Let's get out of my rocket boots.
Okay, I think more luck.
We need height, though.
The key is the height.
We're almost there, guys.
We're so close.
Okay.
Imagine war dogs.
They're like, oh, yeah, I'm close.
Sorry.
can we hit 500 get more luck I need jump height why is it
all just luck
yeah oh my god please just give me it give me fucking jump
height oh it's taking so long to level up now.
It's bad.
That jump rope.
Okay, I think I can do this one.
Okay, I got the beat.
No!
This is bad.
This is pretty bad.
Oh my god.
I'm from... I got a little two.
I got a little two cocky.
Okay, we need a jump rope just so like to be safe.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I'll increase jump height.
It's fine.
We didn't get there.
Slow and steady.
Oh my god, we're under 300k.
We're going to be under 300k soon.
Things we do for war dogs.
Yeah.
We jumped too close to the sun.
War.
War never changes.
Oh, fuck.
I'm going to do.
I know I could reinforce.
force this but I believe I believe guys we gotta invest in
the jump height I don't know when I'll see it again okay oh
this is gonna take fucking forever oh whoa we hit a lucky we
hit a lucky though all right I think I know I get it now I
know why war dog is so popular exactly oh my that was
okay that was so cheap okay we got reinforced i don't trust
myself anymore
all right it's fine we got lucky we got lucky in i got too
greedy there i don't trust myself i need reinforce okay oh
that's close i didn't know where the rope was i lost track
of the rope guys all right oh double lucky oh my god finally
i'm lucky in something oh my god we're on the 300k we're on
the 300k oh that's close okay with more luck equals more
upgrades and more upgrades equals more luck with more please
dad please please don't fuck with my rhythm again please
Yeah, he locked it?
Yeah, I gotta cut it straight.
I gotta lock in.
Okay, I can't get into my flow state.
My trump jump rope float state.
Dad, please.
I'm slurring my words.
Okay.
What?
No.
Go.
All right.
I think I can add another one.
Guys, I don't think I can add another one.
I don't think I can add another one.
I wasted two ropes now.
Two rope upgrades.
I'm just gonna do jump fight.
Rest in peace, new rope.
Alright, it's fine.
We just increased luck.
Alright.
We're getting higher.
We're getting so high now.
Can't you hold it?
It just fucks with my timing if I do...
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Alright, this is the highest I've ever been, guys.
Yeah, now you see the vision on how a porn artist made this.
You guys see the vision now?
Oh, it was animated by a pornitis?
Okay.
Okay, that's scary actually.
I jumped too close to the sun.
It's bob time.
Guys, I'm scared of booting up a different game.
Scandal sent me back in the queue again.
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
I'm even funny in the 69.
The sequel is 69.
time too Dennis thank you a super chat thank you thank you
guys the thing is I'm stuck with scarlet skips because I'm
scared of opening a different game we just broke under 300k
I can't go back to another line guys I can't be sent We
can't be sent back.
They can't do this to me.
Oh my god.
We can't be sent back to the queue.
This is all we have.
my i chose my personal health i can't leave off let's keep
that jumping
that leaves me you'll send me the back of my queue if i if i
stop the other game
chose this i can't what did they send me to the back of the
line
Do it, Doki.
Switch to another game, Doki.
Do it.
Thank you, Kora.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki, if you stop looking at the chesticles, I bet you can
make it to 1,000.
I was on the fence about board hours, but I think I'm going
to get it.
Thanks for showing such a running gameplay.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Kora.
I don't know.
Guys, do you think it'll be worth it?
Do you think?
I'm scared.
I'm scared, guys.
You're still...
There's so many people in front of me.
Oh my god.
Non-Steam games.
The only one.
Okay, let's see.
I'll pull up Gog.
All right, Gog.
It's time.
Maybe if I have Gog out, it'll be okay.
Maybe Gog's the answer.
Let me look up games in GOG.
Alright.
What's on GOG?
What's on GOG today?
Any cool games on GOG?
I don't even know if anybody still uses GOG.
I feel like people use GOG just to buy heroes of might and
magic.
Hmm.
There's no interesting game that I want to play on Gogg.
That's War of the North.
What is this game?
Never heard of it.
I mean, I have.
I sort of heard of it, but I don't know much about it.
Alright, my last kimpop.
I love kimpop.
That was good.
It was a good kimpop.
I just don't know what to play.
because it has to be a one-off game that I can just pull up
while we wait for war ducks it's like an appetizer it's like
the opening act so it has to be like a one-off game that's
not a series so I can fucking pass the fucking time
all at the one-off games are on steam but i don't but i'm
too scared i don't want to go back to the back of the line
guys i'm too scared not again i'm not strong enough i'm not
14 Even a super chat they can think I'm not sure I can't do
this again They can't they can't make me do this again guys
I'm weak Oh, you know what I'm scared of what do I start
downloading the game and then and then war dogs knows
They're like we know what you Oh, is someone cheating on us
again?
And why aren't we getting the maximum amount of bandwidth
right now?
Why?
Back of the line, you go.
We get all your bandwidth or nothing.
I'm golden.
Then give us Super Chat.
Thank you.
It's time for Windows 95.
Space Cadet Pinball.
What is there on Switch right now?
Alright, Switch games.
I don't even remember how to fucking, I'm gonna fucking like
stream on, how to stream on Switch.
I don't even know, I don't know if my Switch is charged.
That's the worst part.
I don't think my Switch is charged.
Oh, actually, wait, I'm fucking, I just need to dock it.
Yeah, never mind.
That should be fine.
What kind of games are on the Switch right now?
I'm looking.
Oh, Splatoon.
Yeah, but Splatoon Ratt is just like, should be like a
series.
Pikachu detective Pikachu returns he's back
What can we do
I just know the only thing I know about The new Splatoon
game is that everybody's gooting to the new girl The
Splatoon girl Alright this looks fun Um Alright let me check
my switch Um
um god my switch is so dusty because i don't know what to do
with it
but this is the power right
yeah the power is right oh all right i'm charging my switch
right now
oh maybe i should have been in the streamer server
Maybe the streamer's server was the heat.
Maybe.
All these streamers look like they're having a blast right
now.
They all sure look like they're having so much fun.
Wish that was me.
That could have been me.
not she's not one no i'm one of you guys i'm in the queue
see i'm just like you i'm in the queue i'm just like you i'm
in the queue
i'm like the squidward meme right now looking through the
window
to me.
I just wanted to play jump rope.
I just, I could have been in.
I would have been in right now.
That's the worst part.
I would have been there.
Wait, wait.
Wait, God.
God.
I'm lower.
I think I saw, oh my God.
God, guys, guys, guys, short for us 240,000.
I'm 233.
Guys, I'm 10K ahead.
I'm 10K ahead.
I, we can do this.
We, we're not last.
We're not last.
or at least 10k ahead
There's still hope there's still hope there's still hope
there's still hope in the world guys guys do not give up
guys there's still hope there's still hope in this world oh
I don't remember how to set up my I don't remember how to
set up for switch screen uh
to set up the the switch game capture
all right we'll be it'll be fine it'll be fine guys uh we
got this it's it's gonna we're gonna get there oh i'm
worried if i download a game game on like i'm worried like
war dogs will know it's like they're in my in my walls right
now they i think the one i'm most worried about is that if i
download a game and then war dog's like where is this other
downloading coming from
why am i not getting a hundred percent of the bandwidth
dokey bird game behind my back.
They're in my Wi-Fi.
They're in my router.
Like, huh.
Oh, it wouldn't be a shame if I disconnect you right now.
Like, wouldn't it be a shame?
I'm so scared.
I can't, I guess I'm not strong enough.
I hate the toxic relationship.
I'm sorry I will never cheat on you.
Today is a war dog only day.
Huh.
Seems like you're enjoying your day waiting in this queue.
Are you playing something right now, Jokey Bird?
How can that be?
When, oh, are you trying to cheat on me behind my back
again, Rory?
Jokey Bird?
Doug, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We need to sacrifice the dragon to please the war dog, God,
so that doesn't reset a second time, Doug.
If it resets, it's like, I'm out.
I'm tapping out.
I cannot.
I cannot queue.
I cannot queue again.
Oh, my God.
We're under a 200K.
We're under 200K, guys.
Oh.
See, the only thing I have downloaded on my Switch was is is
Pokapia is Pokapia and that's it I think I like I like
because I don't I think I like didn't download anything else
on my new Switch.
I literally just bought the Switch for Pokapia and then we
did one stream of Pokapia and
I'm worried if I download something else I'm too scared.
I don't even want I don't want to risk it.
Guys, do you think my boot up Minecraft?
It'll kick me out, guys.
Is it worth it?
Is it worth the risk to get on Minecraft?
Probably.
Yes.
Will I get punished?
I'll make a fault.
Is it worth or should I just sit there like a good little
boy?
I just let him do this to me.
I'm so scared.
All right.
Let's see.
I'll make a pull.
Why risk it and cheat on war dogs behind their back with
Minecraft?
Always.
Yes.
Oh, yeah, I have the Mataji light.
That's true.
What are they doing right now?
Just don't tell them.
Get another phone, right?
Surely this can go well.
Why vote yes.
We might have a lot of cheaters in chat.
Oh, 170k.
Oh, my gosh.
I don't know if that's right.
You tell.
This is going to be another hour.
This is going to be another fucking hour.
I think that's the worst part.
It's going to be another hour of my fucking life.
The game won't know.
We'll be really, really good at hiding it.
14.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
One hour of just nothing or Minecraft.
I can't thank you for the magenta soup, but thank you.
Thank you.
Wait, we can play Fortnite.
Everybody's vote no now.
Vote no.
And this is where it's like, vote no now.
Oh my god, you're right.
Guys, wait, I can play Fortnite.
Oh my god, it's going down.
Everyone's like...
And they're like, everyone's like, oh god.
No, okay, well if it's for a nap, changing my phone.
The phone is gas.
I voted Minecraft, not for it.
I take back my phone.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh my god, it's actually going down.
All right, all right, wait, wait, wait.
a new pull make a new it is so don't you have so many
mistresses no you don't know that though all right amending
pull all right all right wait wait new pull new pull go back
go back go back is that correct thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you
worry we'll be very safe 157 wait we're getting there i
think we could get in before too guys we might be able to
get oh my gosh my chat is like
all right oh my god it's like stuck at zero percent we'll
never know we'll never know Wait, is YouTube dying or is
just war dogs actually punishing me right now?
No pull broke.
I broke the pull.
We'll never know.
Wait, if I end pull, what will it tell me?
We can't even end it?
Is it actually just a zero?
Only two.
No!
Okay, okay, we'll do it.
We'll do it again.
Fortnite.
Alright, here you go.
I smelled...
Oh my god.
I... I wrote cheek.
I just... I wrote cheek.
Whatever.
It's fine.
I don't care.
I don't care anymore.
Life is... life.
I'm still...
I just noticed it.
As you don't understand, I'm fucking going crazy right now.
I feel like I've been waiting for 80 years of my life.
It's been like almost two hours, and I still have yet to
play the game.
This could have been us at 1230.
Like, I...
This could have been a lot worse.
We could have been doing this since 1230.
I would play like a browser game but I haven't set anything
up for a browser game and I'm I get super paranoid so
I don't want to risk it right now
I would be playing right now too I just ate some good
tamales dokey and you're streaming too so I get to eat good
and be entertained thank you the super chat out thank you
thank you
have Mind Sweeper here.
I don't even have guys, I don't even have Mind Sweeper
installed on this on this PC.
We unfortunately do not have Mind Sweeper.
Yeah.
If I download Mind Sweeper, will it kick me out of the
queue?
We're so close, guys.
Guys, we're we're so close, guys.
We're literally We're almost back to under a hundred K.
I we're That's the thing Patrick has to do they're all like
on on online So like I don't have anything set up for online
stuff, too So it's like I don't have like I need like pre
set it up.
I want to do anything On a browser because I'm worried I'll
leak stuff like I always get so paranoid that I'll leak
things so I I I just don't do anything unless I don't do
anything on the internet on browser stuff unless I
pre-prepared it
Uh mint raven thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I left to buy nachos at like 90k people in kiewit and god's
name happened I got I got caught Ward dog is a very very it
gets very jealous very easily They get very jealous.
Meep, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Will this kick you back into Q on Xbox upon earning
achievements like starting Overwatch 2?
Meep, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, I couldn't boot up Overwatch 2.
I'm just so scared.
I'm scared if I boot up anything.
They'll know.
oh my god they they're very needy war dogs is very
possessive and needy i just we're so close we're wait guys
we can't we can't we gotta sit here we gotta look away we
can't guys like we can't we're literally almost say i can't
do this again i can't go back to 300k i we're literally
almost freaking 100k oh my god god this is gonna be fucking
weird this.
I'm so sorry.
My dog.
I'm gonna hold him.
Wait.
I'm gonna walk my dog.
It doesn't even matter.
I'm gonna... I'm walking.
I'm walking my dog.
I'm walking my... I might as well.
I might as well take time to walk him like what else am i
gonna do you can't kick me out of the queue if i'm walking
my fucking dog that's that's not online that's like oh what
if you don't say that don't say that there's no way there's
it's like if we're always like you're not sitting on your pc
tom the
It's like you have to be here and sit here and watch the
numbers go down.
Oh, I see you're not on your PC right now I can tell your
mouse isn't moving They have like an AI to detect my mouse
movement so they'll know that they'll know that I'm not
there because their mouse isn't moving And I'm back in the
line if you're gonna amk minus while amk in the back
I'll be right back.
Oh my god.
I can't hold on to it.
I don't understand.
I wanted to walk with him out now.
I was able.
I managed to walk my dog.
I can't even walk.
my dog in this economy what can I even do I can't get
nothing I actually had to sit there and wait I
this would not have happened if you jump rope better and Gus
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
Nobody's thinking with a super chat, they can think how fast
are you running.
Nobody's thinking with a super chat, they can think you
can't think of any Akasufa.
They can think, we believe that.
I can't believe it.
I got it.
There's no way it kicked me out because that was AFK.
If there's, okay, if there was an update I didn't download,
how will I know?
Is it because with the authenticate?
Is it because of the authenticate that I have an update that
I didn't download?
Is that it?
Oh, my God.
Is there an update that I didn't download?
is why okay oh my god
do I do I risk it do I get out of the queue and update the
game and get back in do I do I risk it I am more worried
that I have a, I'm, I'm, I'm worried.
I'm so worried.
No, do not do.
There's too many risks.
Okay.
Dad, please.
I'm suffering.
Oh.
You don't, it will skip it.
Think about it.
Don't up there it will skip you again oh my god do i do i i
don't know i i don't know i i don't know if i should risk it
i don't know i don't know anymore i've been in purgatory for
so long i left to walk for like less than 10 minutes
for for less than 10 minutes the war really isn't changing
be fine it's it's it's going to be fine
It'll be fine.
It's going to be fine.
Everything will be okay.
We're 86,000.
Surely it won't happen a third time.
The dragon sacrifice of us, Kevin.
Surely.
Surely this won't happen a third time, right?
Surely, surely you'll be okay.
It's only going down by 1k.
I don't.
All
I can do is just sit here.
That's all I can do.
Ordog doesn't want me to do anything else.
All I can do is just sit there.
Kiyago, thank you for the super chat.
that's the worst part that's i all i can do is just sit
there i can't i can't leave i can't leave because then it'll
be failed to authenticate failed to exist i've been here for
two hours i i've been here for two hours
know and they started checking the in game this game spawn
there's my microphone and i'm moving my mouse i'm look look
war dogs i was never seeing a super chat they could think
look look war dogs look mouse is moving i'm not afk i i'm
here to oh my god it actually is going 1k oh my god how was
it going so fast it was going it was like like what a
hundred plus k when i went out to walk my dog and then i
came back and we were it was like 5k i oh my god i don't
understand how how did it go by so fast when i yeah when i
was walking my dog when it took Fucking forever to go down.
Nine K skips at a time.
And now, now that I'm here.
Now that I'm here.
It's going 1 K.
1 K.
Like little, little tiny little footstuffs.
Like, boop, boop, boop, boop.
We're almost there.
Boop, boop, boop.
I don't understand.
Go watch.
go out and walk dad again oh my god we only dropped 4 3k
it's only been 3k I've been sitting here I'm actually
sitting here waiting it's only been 3k and but somehow when
I'm not there when I'm not entertain yourself, i'm gonna lie
i'm gonna fucking disassociate in my bed, i'm gonna
i'm ordering ice i deserve ice cream i i deserve ice cream i
hate ice cream this girl, this is ice cream time i'm
ordering ice cream after this all right ice cream ice queen
we need somewhere like close by i don't want my ice cream
getting melted that's the worst part of ordering ice cream
that has to be like somewhere close
um i want like a i don't want like a giant fucking jar of
ice cream i just want tag ice cream
oh my god the closest is Baskin Robbins.
Oh my god.
Another 1K.
Oh, at least like...
At least like...
Sure, four has to wait.
Apparently...
He got in a queue to wait in another queue.
It's the little things.
I don't even...
Guys, if I have to get in just to wait in another queue
because it's been 10...
Apparently it's been like almost 10 minutes and he's still
in another queue to get into a server, because to get into,
like, the friend server.
And, like, at this point, if that's the case, I might just
queue up.
I might just put me in anywhere.
Like, I just want to play at least one game.
Just put me in anywhere.
I don't care.
Might as well.
Like, I'm sorry.
I can't.
I cannot do another queue.
I waited.
I got sent back in line three times.
I can't do it again.
The fact that we're queuing up to go to war.
To go to fucking war.
If you get ice cream with war dogs and heck the joy in your
life and push you.
You're not suffering hard enough.
Back to the queue you go.
all right dad i'm picking you up i'm picking you up that's
it
all right he's in my arms now he's he's in my arm
oh another one kid oh i'm gonna cream still i'm gonna get
two scoops that's right i'm going wild getting two scoops
cotton candy and let's see what do i want i think i made
rainbow sprinkles that's right rainbow sprinkles what else
do i want honey and cotton candy the game is preventing the
Canadian from inventing new warcrafts.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, I don't know.
I don't know if I'm strong enough.
Guys, I'm this close to this.
Guys, guys, guys, if we don't get in after, if we're still
not in, if this is the last time, if they sent me to the
back of the line after this, if they if i i swear to god i
swear to god if i get sent to a back of the line again it's
over it it's it's over i i cannot do it a fourth time guys i
i cannot i'm not strong enough to do it a fourth time i
can't keep walking into the back of the line i
I can't do that strong enough.
I guess I can't send me back.
I can't queue again.
It's just...
It's over.
I swear, if I see the...
If I see the authenticator thing, I'm ending stream.
I'm eating cotton candy ice back to the lab.
You're not allowed to feel joy.
Poor limb.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Why didn't I get into the streamer service?
Why didn't I ask about the streamer service?
Why didn't I ask to get whitelisted?
Why am I for the people?
At least you have your arm, war dog, to make up for the
weight for war dogs.
And yes, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But the people, one of us, one of us, messaged them right
now on the streamer server.
It's only 7K, but the people don't keep the people.
Some of you didn't have to go back to the line three fucking
times.
Some of you didn't have to do what I did.
In fact, I'm the most down-to-earth streamer right now on
War Dogs.
I went back three fucking times.
Ice cream review stream.
Woohoo.
Do good.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Some of the people already in.
okay i think that's how to get you so you can't refund the
game if you're stuck in a two plus hour queue how can you
refund the game you couldn't even play how can you refund if
you've been in queue on the whole two hours that's how
they're like well you're on the game for two minute that's
why they keep sending me back oh this is what did someone
say this game was developed by people from by the British
did someone just said that that would make so much sense
there's they love waiting in lines how do they even
determine the queue position just launched the game but
somehow I'm ahead of you.
It's like they don't want me to play.
It's like, it's like, I've been marked.
What's the word?
You know, in like multiplayer game when they mark you and
then like they put you in worse queues.
So they gave me a, they gave me a mark.
They gave me a community note.
be like make sure she's at the furthest back of the line
like yeah i'm on low prime i'm on losers queue right now
i've been like i'm on a black list i'm on the list they
flagged my account they're like will cheat on your game with
other games wouldn't can't even wait in the line like all
the others like it is impatient they flagged my account to
the back of the queue i go
not loyal yeah doki you like that huh now that you like now
that you're like on my lab you're such a little bitch oh the
only that's cookie dough what do i want i'm the only the
flavor i want the most is cotton candy oh you know what i'll
grab this Oh, grab.
I don't like Rocky Road, so...
This chocolate chip cookie doll, but that's so sweet.
I don't want something that's... Okay, I got it.
Alright.
It's because I already have cotton candy, and I think that's
already enough.
Like, that's sweet enough.
Alright.
I'm ordering my ice cream.
If I look up from my phone after I order ice cream, and then
I see...
and then I see that they kicked me out of it oh my god I'm
still so far so far back I'm ordering my one ice cream I'm
doing priority I don't care I'm paying that extra six
dollars I don't care I just it's been two hours and 30
minutes I'm I'm ordering I juke gave me five pounds thank
you for the queue and i'm using that five pounds to work at
priority queue at least i'll be priority in something at
least at least this is priority so thank you for super chat
thank you thank you thanks toky for she goes back to the end
of the line so that some of us may move forward yes yes when
i was about to go in i saw an old granny um waiting outside
um and i knew that like this was her this was her last day
on earth and i was like you know what granny you deserve to
be in the front instead of here take my spot and that's why
i'm for the people i i was like oh oh you poor thing i know
before you die you want to play some war dogs before you go
thank you it's going faster it's still 56 000 and guys don't
give me hope it's still so far
still so far It starts really faster when you ordered ice
cream.
It does.
I swear to God, I swear to God, guys, if I go pee, it's at
5K again.
And, sorry, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm going to do it.
I need to go to the bathroom.
I need to pee.
Don't you fall?
I'm doing, I'm taking the risk.
i need to be i'm sorry i need to use the bathroom i'll be
right back
okay we made okay it's not that bad it's not that bad it's
not i i left them we're at 36 it knows it knows whenever i
leave it it knows it it tried it tried so hard it forward
thank you forward solid many two game on you papa bite,
blazing, dead weight.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No true war dog holds it.
And back to the queue, you go.
It knows every time I'm here, every time I'm watching, the
queue slows down.
But if I leave for even one second, watch this.
I'm going to go see that.
And then the queue's gonna go down
oh oh it knows it knows it's listening it's it's it's
listening it actually is listening i'm like oh my god it's
playing me.
It's like 70.
Thank you.
Let's see your chart.
Sorry about that.
Thank you.
Let's see your chart.
He's listening.
I...
What is that chainsaw?
Chainsaw man meme?
What is that meme again?
That's basically how I feel right now.
It's not going down anymore.
Wow, what a coincidence that it's not going down anymore.
You know what?
I love War Dogs.
War Dogs is a very fun game.
I love this game so much, and I'm glad that...
I'm glad...
I'm glad that they are very successful in how...
many people want to play their game and and how it's how um
how they're having so much love right now and i you know i
love this queue i hope they send me back again again to
another line i
with the super chat.
Thank you.
Don't say that.
Don't say that, Tookie.
They're gonna do it out of spite.
Tookie, don't do it.
Oh my god.
Oh, don't please.
Please, our 820k.
We're...
Fucking, oh my god, we're We're sub 20 now.
It's sub 20.
We're almost there Or else
I'm not strong enough if I see failed to authenticate if I
Fucking see failed to authenticate if I for Time I can't I
can't guys I can't I can't I can't guys I can't I can't I
can't I'm not I'm I'm not strong enough I am not strong
enough for this I can't I can't do this again I can't I
can't we're so close it's been 80 years I I was born and I
died this cute
I'll have my my deathbed will be at my PC Still waiting in
the war dogs queue Oh my god, let's have the music on
Oh my hello guy who got ahead of you I'm in The guy oh my
god
6k Oh 6k and my ice cream they're picking up my ice cream i
don't want to click on anything i'm so scared i'm so scared
okay okay 6k we just wait we just wait it's all coming
together it's all it's all coming in together guys why does
6k make me happy this is it this is what we've been waiting
for this we've been waiting for right here right now two out
two hours and four almost three hours in queue almost three
hours in queue but we are player 506 we are player five